gérald vissé en tournage aujourd'hui
donc on vous joins à sherbrooke
première chose qu'on voudrait savoir
gerald c est ce que c'était inévitable
est ce que rona avait le choix
c'est vrai que ona a quand même connu
des années difficiles ça pas été facile
dans les dernières années
les résultats n'ont pas été au
rendez-vous la restructuration n'a pas
été facile
l'entreprise donc pas de décision
d'entreprise entend aujourd'hui nous
avons une entente amicale
ça ira mieux dans le futur que de faire
ça avec l'os que de faire ça contre lose
mais moi je me rappelle en 2002 que
rhône a été lancée en bourse à toronto
c'était tout un événement rona était à
la conquête du canada aujourd'hui en
décidant de signer avec klose et donc de
laisser l'eau acheter les activités de
rona on a l'impression que cette
entreprise a baissé les bras devant son
concurrent
en tout cas on peut dire que ça relance
tout le débat sur les sièges sociaux
absolument parce qu'il ya eu beaucoup de
paroles politiques mais il ya eu un peu
d'action pour savoir comment on protège
des sièges sociaux du québec et dans
l'ensemble du canada
yvan allaire qui est le président de
l'institut sur la gouvernance disait
l'intérêt des actionnaires c'est une
chose est ici dans cette transaction
l'intérêt des actionnaires et
certainement bien protéger la preuve la
caisse de dépôt appuie la transaction
mais les intérêts économiques dans une
transaction que ce soit une offre
amicale ou une offre hostile les
intérêts économiques les fournisseurs
les clients les milieux économiques
est-ce que ça s'est prise en compte dans
la décision yvan allaire affirme qu'il
ya des protections beaucoup plus sévères
aux etats-unis qu'au québec et au canada
là dessus et est ce qu'il pourrait y en
avoir d'autres parce qu'avec la chute du
dollar canadien est ce qu'on doit
craindre une accélération des ventes des
entreprises canadiennes et c'est seule
vraie question ce soir ces kits prochain
est ce que c'est snc lavalin est ce que
c'est mais trop est-ce que c'est des
entreprises de ressources ailleurs au
canada
la chute du dollar canadien rend très
très intéressante l'acquisition d'une
entreprise au québec ou d'une entreprise
ailleurs au canada juste vous donner une
statistique là les sièges sociaux du
québec représentaient 24% du poids
canadiens en 2001 on est rendu à 20% en
la chute du dollar canadien pourrait
accélérer cette tendance
mais le fait qu'on
une un siège social canadien ce que
c'est pas une bonne nouvelle ça ça peut
être une bonne nouvelle effectivement à
court terme et à moyen terme
mais il faudra voir à long terme ce que
ça vous de ce que ça va donner on a vu
des exemples comme la bourse de montréal
est revendue à toronto
c'est toronto qui décide alcan est
revendue à rio tinto on sait que c'est à
londres et en australie que les
décisions se prennent c'est la perte
quand même d'un pouvoir décisionnel et y
est pas garantie qu'on n'aura pas perdu
davantage dans cinq ou dix ans avec la
transaction aujourd'hui voilà merci
beaucoup gerald au revoir